what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Saucon super pumped to
be talking about the fallacious self we
have dr. Jurgen Kramer joining us on the
show hi you're good not to be here
thanks so much for coming on the show
what a cool lineage we've had recently
with interviewing Charles Eisenstein
than him recommending bio coma laughs a
and then you coming with the bio to the
studio for the his interview and then
now we have you on the show I love it
thanks so much that's wonderful it's a
beautiful lineage that now we get to
express together and create together
through for those who don't know your
guns background he's an author and
professor of behavioral sciences at
Santa Rosa Junior College where he's
focused on abnormal and general
psychology as well as transformations of
consciousness and you can find his link
in the bio below
you're gonna very similar question that
we had to start our shows off with
Charles and also with bio about and most
recently with so many of our guests on
this topic we find ourselves here
embedded in this creation why are we
here what is the purpose of this well
the answer that I grew up with is self
actualization to bring ourselves fully
to life to integrate ourselves
I think another version of this which I
think comes out of the Sufi tradition is
so that god or goddess may know herself
and understand herself and experience
ourself fully so the more we integrate
the more we experience ourselves
including
dividing and spiritual aspects which I
don't see a separate from our emotional
and material and all of that so that
would be my short answer oh that yeah
brilliant articulation yeah yes
self-actualization create that's Maslow
and Carl Rogers and others talked about
this in the humanistic existential
tradition so that means when we do
therapy that we deal with the obstacles
the diversions that keep us from
actually bringing forth our gifts or our
medicines as it were what we are have
been gifted with and actualizing that so
each of us also as nerve endings of
creation expressing itself in self
actualizing have unique gifts to bring
forth into creation and that it is then
up to our social fabric as we're gonna
get into it's up to it's not just I'm
here in this body and that's it it is
I'm embedded in a culture I'm embedded
in a planetary you even physical
biospheric psychology so this is so
deeply interconnected so that has the
social fabric can get more and more
stronger at helping us express ourselves
as those nerve endings of creation and
bring our gifts forward so this is where
the fallacious self comes in because the
term really refers to that the way in
our current times and modernity and even
to extend and post modernity and
modernity understand ourselves is that
we are separate from all these things
that you've just listed that we've taken
ourselves out of it and it's like we are
all in control and it's just us
so there's a whole amnesia that's
happening
yeah where these interconnections both
with culture but with the biosphere are
they're still there but they are not in
our awareness they're not part of our
lives so part of if we want to so we are
performing a fallacious self or what I
like to call normative dissociation
we're split off
we're split off from all these sources
that could feed us whether that's nature
whether that's integrated integrative
states of consciousness alterations of
consciousness or whether that's
community the holistic medicines yeah
all of that and so healing ourselves
from this pathology really means
remembering where we're coming from so
spiritual amnesia it's it's it's
spiritual amnesia it's social in nature
it's cultural amnesia
it's an amnesia in our scientific
paradigm it's a big pathology and when
we talked earlier you know you mentioned
you reminded me of the Einstein quote
you know where we're in Stein talks
about in this letter about the delusion
of separateness yeah and that in so many
ways is foundational you know and one of
the things that I don't believe in I
actually believe in very very few things
but one of the things I don't believe in
is ma no causal explanations mmm
everything so severe yet we are you know
we are complex
we're complicated and we have many more
variables than we can even possibly
control but also we can possibly
understand so when I say normative
disassociation I mean I think that's a
big explanation in there but it's not
the only explanation and you know the
other people who recently had
conversations here Chris Ryan and
Kamala fey and Charles Einstein you know
they illuminate kind of the same topics
from slightly different angles and has
slightly different explanations and part
of it is we're trying to language
something that actually is difficult to
language that's you know that you know
it's actually easier to experience or
into it then to language it's much
easier to express in imagery rather than
in words it's in it's easier to feel the
interconnectedness or to express it may
be in imagery video these types of
things than it is to try and ascribe
words to the interconnectedness yeah of
all yeah damn yeah even mmm interesting
just that word I think
interconnectedness does a pretty good
job but yeah well I actually you know I
started to think about this
interconnectedness entanglement you know
and probably my most preferred term and
they're all okay but my most preferred
term is intimacy being intimate with the
world yeah and we've really disconnected
ourselves our norm is that the way we
look at ourselves in our individualistic
society is that we are disconnected from
the sources that can nurture us and that
can inspire us you know again you know
nature whether we go into meditation or
whatever we do and we listen to the
waves all these things that are can feed
us yeah I really deeply admire that the
intimacy we just yesterday were
unpacking this with Ori on the show as
well where Ori was talking about it
in a in a devotion at even the smallest
level devotion to the water that is
being sipped that it sustains is
devotion to that bite of food devotion
to the breath of air devotion to that
deep of interconnectedness right that's
life-changing that is and then there is
that side which is kind of the spiritual
religious side and then the there's the
other side that's a very practical side
which relates to sustainability and and
those issues because we are no longer
intimate with the environment we don't
understand the environment we try to
control it we abuse it for profit we
turn everything into data and profit and
all of that and so having that intimacy
can actually you know teach us how we
could be sustainable so in that sense I
would say everybody needs to become
black everybody needs to become
indigenous everybody needs to become red
or whatever metaphor you want to you
want to use and remember that that's
actually the capacity that we have it's
a capacity that since the Renaissance
with the rise of modernity we have
forgotten and part of that is we are so
left brain oriented that we've created
this Hall of Mirrors as in the Gilchrist
would say
that we're now caught in it's a prisoner
man you know the way is out you know by
you always looks for the crack scenes
where are the cracks you know he is of
course you know what our right
hemisphere does what our dreams do what
happens in meditation all these things
can help us you know artistic creativity
all of that can help us get out of this
prison but the prison is so highly
valued and is so predominant because
it's all entangled with profit and how
we make a living yeah you know and so
when I talk about fallacious self you
know it's an epistemology it's an
ontology it's an ethic that is you know
fallacious that we perform everyday our
society pushes us to perform in that way
and it's difficult to step out of that
and remember who we are and what our
capacities are and that we all have
indigenous roots yes yes Wow so this
Hall of Mirrors that has been built is
in a sense the exact evolutionary
trajectory that is going to make it so
that we truly learn the realness of the
interconnectedness the realness of the
love our our ability to swing back from
these depths of disconnectedness and and
deep immersion into the the self is
what's going to enable us to really feel
the deep interconnectedness there's a
couple other things I just want to
quickly also mention which was that you
give this example of in a sense to me it
feels like this big board game and it's
a big board game of Monopoly of risk
that has just been developed and that
when a child is born into the world the
first thing again we
been talking about this on the show is
that there's immediate trauma in the
sense of being told that you are
separate the parents aren't in the
community and social fabric is not
saying you are interconnected with
everything from the moment that you're
coming that you're coming in here and
because of that that's when this first
bit of separation starts that the West
had this whole thing with the self the
individualism which has been incredible
in many ways and also has been
disconnecting in other ways and to be
able to find these basic indigenous
principles of all coming from the same
source and us being able to be able to
grasp that the deepest parts of that
ethos and bring that into our modernity
and figure out how to maximize
prosperity with those ethos is one of
the most important things where is the
exit door I always ask that question
there is no exit door anymore
there's the what used to be living on
land and being deeply interconnected
with that land and with each other in
the tribal days and the inclusive
fitness days has become rampant self
dealing and lack of inclusive stake
holding with the environment and with
each other and here we have this big fat
board game that you're born into you're
immediately do you have a house no you
don't well guess what now you are gonna
be paying $1,000 a month in rent in that
what do you I'm immediately burdened
with needing to go and make you see this
is the cycle and so we just were so
deeply embedded within it when to snap
out of this requires the experiential
feelings of of non separation yes it
does and you know for for me the
contrast is really indigenous societies
at their core you know and it's always
hard to generalize and I also really
just want to say that you know
indigenous societies also do have flaws
have an insight and an intuition yeah in
their performance of knowledge and
living you know they perform knowledge
they embody no knowledge that we can
learn from and you know we have made
this separation this dissociation
because we've said well they're
primitive and racist science comes in
there you know that enabled colonization
is what was part of the process of
colonization in all of that so what is
different about the performance of
indigenous knowing and it's really not
just a knowing it's a knowing being that
kind of times put these two words
together which sort of makes it a little
high daguerreian for better or worse but
you know like when I last summer I
wasn't Hopi and I had the opportunity to
observe a Kachina dance which is you
know one of their most sacred ceremonies
and cool it is about you know it is not
purposive in the same sense than we
understand purpose you know because our
purpose is always its its control it's
you know maximize profit it's that we we
have that linearity right and this is
working with all the forces the beings
the presences the land the history all
of that together in this performance and
as a way of balancing so I talked about
you know self-actualization earlier you
know part of that is that we balance
ourselves and part of the struggle with
languaging these things is so often
especially in English we have to use and
now
well in fact we should use a verb these
are all this processes you know it's
nothing you find balance right when
somebody who walks on a tightrope finds
balance it stops moving he or she is
gonna fall off the tightrope right so
it's a continuous process you know it's
ongoing and it's never a sure that's
ongoing work is that the ad bin flow I'm
not sure what you have in mind when you
say a band flow but but it's like we're
never perfect right in situations change
right and we make mistakes right but
also the seasons change or animals
migrate or somebody does something
stupid right and so we always need to be
in this process of balancing balancing
ourselves inside the world around us and
actually intimately intimately exactly
and that's out of my mouth and that's
what you were describing with the
indigenous ceremony that was happening
it was a deep balance over themselves
with all other things that they're
interconnected - right and you know you
have the sense when you go to some of
these ceremonies that you know they have
been done for hundreds of years in one
form or another and there is this
ancient memory now all of us either
Armenian and German or whatever we are
somewhere in our history had that you
know and you know Carl Gustav Jung talks
about it in terms of the collective
unconscious those deep deep deep
memories yeah we all carry that and you
know we have just trained our brains not
to go there it's not that we cannot go
there but we've trained ourselves our
educational system all of that trains us
not in to go there which is why we have
this tremendous spiritual hunger
which is a little bit different for a
need for religion by spiritual hunger I
mean experience you know direct
encounters with something that is larger
and divine - whatever you want to call
that and you know that's why there is
again a resurgence of the use of
entheogens the trances meditation in
that interest because you know we're
trying to look for these states that
actually help us with integration I also
loved how you're mentioning this this
something that's so deep within us that
we're going on this quest to find this
deep interconnectedness this deep
intimacy that we have with each other
with creation with why we're all here
and I think one of the reasons why like
you were mentioning dance is something
that is so primordial II with us I think
why so many people in today's day love
going out and partying and dancing and
the electronic music festivals and stuff
like that it does kind of take us to
that primordial collective dancing an
environment well you know look at the
Grateful Dead concerts you know I mean
they're probably maybe at the prime
example with rock music where you have
this you know and where this this need
you know the thing is we can be denied
in denial about it but the need doesn't
go away you know the thing is we're
still untangled yeah we're still
interrelated the question is are we
conscious of it you know are we engaging
with it and are we making that part of
our performance of who we are part of
our embodiment and so that's from the
where for me these this Kachina dances
so beautiful because you see it there
you know and it's also there's a lot of
gift-giving it
you know it's communal you know there
other ceremonies there for individuals
but this is a communal ceremony and
celebration and so that is a shift in in
consciousness
yeah and there's so many other of these
principles that these main pillars of
ethos from our most ancestral days that
can be properly embodied in our
modern-day society that will help ensure
a bright or future for us all okay we
mentioned a couple of these things along
the way
already the recovery of this indigenous
mind the optical delusion of separate
let's start with the first term care so
you know one thing is we all have that
potential that has never gone away for
white folks like me we need to deal with
a history well how come we are in this
place how did we get here Yeah right
there indigenous peoples all over the
globe who have continued their practice
of presence of engaging of being
nurtured by everything around and
nurturing what is around them and that's
kind of an Indian philosophy how can we
are disconnected so that's the shadow of
racism colonialism and all of that how
come I'm in the position as I was
growing up that I wasn't participating
in that right that I wasn't trained in
that awareness and that all my schooling
didn't mention any of that yeah and
they're dealing with the shadow which is
heart which is always hard to go there
it's it's it's never fun as the young in
say there's gold there yeah there's gold
out there yes and only if
honestly look at that yes and then
transformation can start to happen so
recovery of indigenous mind you can to
do a spiritual shortcut mm-hm
well let me just talk to the gods this
is my afternoon don't talk to the gods
right this is well how come I'm in this
position that I have not nurtured these
connections most of my life all right
how come yeah and once you've answered
that question you become grounded and
with that grounding there's a lot of
pain and you know it because it's a
trauma it's a cultural trauma so there's
there's pain there's sadness about you
know how come I'm in this isolated
individualistic sense of self rather
than into in an interconnected grounded
self that I could perform so the
question is then what were the reasons
why we ended up at this place what
caused us to get to this place and then
to look back at that honestly find the
gold in the shadow and also I love your
way of talking about naturing and
nurturing with the environment around
you and not just this idea of just my
child no it's the entire environment
around you so how come we ended up here
so think opioids think addiction think
you may have seen the movie the gods are
crazy must be crazy
mmm whatever the movie title or the co
model drops from the sky I mean and it
gets the whole competitive game going
right Leslie Marmon Silko in her
powerful novel ceremony has a scene that
is really central to the book where
these witches meet and they're doing a
witches competition who has the greatest
power who has the most powerful
medicines and they all pull out their
thoth skins and the snap cut off fingers
and whatever they had bats and stuff and
then at the end one which speaks up and
saying all I have is a story and the
story she tells is the story basically
of Western progress huh and she tells
the story of how people come across the
ocean etcetera etc etc and the other
witches say we don't like that story and
the storyteller which says it's too late
the story is loose so there is something
addictive why about Wow the story and
there's a psychologist by the name of
Phil Cushman he has analyzed this and I
think he has just really hit it on the
head there he talks about when
specifically for this country when
people came to this country the settlers
the colonizers they left something
behind that they were trying to get away
from either persecution or poverty or
whatever it was so most of them didn't
want to have anything to do with where
they came from so they didn't bring a
tradition now there were two other
things here there were Native American
traditions well they couldn't really go
there because they were all primitive
right there were backwards right they
didn't understand the route they didn't
believe in God they were not Christians
right then we have the other trauma
which is the slave trade mm-hmm right so
these are part of the forces so out of
that comes an empty self right because
that's not held that hat doesn't have a
story that doesn't have a story about
the interconnection because part of how
we hold interconnection is we have
stories about it yes because one of the
most beautiful things about the human
mind is well we can all observe
surrounded whether it's the Redwoods the
whatever is here right but then we also
have an imagination we need a story
opinion right and the people over the
hill may take tell a somewhat different
story a slightly different story right
so they had an empty self well how do
you fill the empty self you consume you
you could shop shop that's one of many
abilities and addictions to pornography
or addictions because you have an
emptiness that you can't exist shopping
- consumerism conspicuous consumers and
so you also have to flaunt it around to
other people that know how to fit yeah
this and it never satisfies the deepest
need for the grounding of the self the
interconnection of the self it just
deals with the symptoms with yeah it's a
surface this is so it's like any
addiction you need more and you need
more and you need more and you need more
and so we're in an addictive
pathological paradigm yeah yeah that's a
very profound way to synthesize it
absolutely great and an addictive
pathological paradigm where it's so far
into the separate self that it has now
become so visibly transparently
cancerous there's no more hiding anymore
the awakening is pushing from all
different aspects from the media from
the government from health and wellness
from family from just deep consciousness
from indigenous principles there's just
no more trying to find some sneaky way
to keep the monopolistic system running
in the same old archaic machinery that
it's been running in well that's you
saying it which is beautiful
but I think there are a lot of people
who are not seeing it or not feeling it
right because part of the nature of
dissociation is that you forget or that
also have economic incentive to keep
going yeah course yeah yeah and we
didn't shattering those incumbents is
critical in progressing into the new
world yes you were saturated yeah and I
you know one interpretation of Donald
Trump as president from a psychological
perspective is that he really brings the
shadow out and that this is a time where
we have a choice of really dealing with
the shadow of material that this society
has not dealt with the shadow of the
history of racism etc etc inequality
what-have-you
right and he makes that so visible that
even when you are in denial it gets
harder and harder to be in denial you
know you have an ideology that denies
and says oh no this is all fine the
Texas tax code changes are for you right
but then you know eventually that that
breaks down so I think we are in that
sense in a critical period you know all
these terms like evolution or any of
that I think are problematic in the
sense that it it suggests an inevitable
linearity you know and I'm not saying
that there hasn't been evolution of
course there has been an evolution but
our evolution is a human species I think
it's up for grabs whether we're gonna
make it or not whether we actually are
going to wake up and whether we actually
whatever it is that we are learning now
or that we could be learning now mm-hmm
whether we actually realize what that is
yeah
and it's up for grabs it it is up for
grabs and it's and I think you know part
of this for me
I'm an educator so when I see what
education does well education initiates
you exactly into that dissociative self
yup and part of you know there's a
powerful a book called the hacking of
the American mind bye-bye elastic is
that you see I said we had him on the we
had him on the show
oh great love rob bluster yeah yeah he's
great yeah but you see there how this
dissociation goes down to the level of
our neurotransmitters yeah right you
know where we become these dopamine
monkeys or whatever yes and that stops
us right so actually the way I'm going
to change teaching introduction to
psychology is I'm going to start out
with what's the psychological challenge
for you what is it that you need to
learn and this kind of awareness is
something that everybody desperately
needs yeah and so yes um that's a big
addiction that's uh yeah yeah that's a
lot of people have we all love our
technology and part of the challenge is
really you know there's nothing wrong
with technology per se it's the profit
motive that distorts it and our will we
actually be able to use these tools as
tools right and not as our part of our
identity right where we can say yeah an
iPhone it's kind of like a hammer it's
kind of like whatever a bicycle it gets
us from here to there or horse or
whatever a horse is not a tool but you
know something that we can use
but that euro is not our identity right
and when we don't have it we don't break
down my my daughter goes to a summer
camper for four weeks no screens boom
and yeah you know you can imagine for a
14-year old you know and she loves it
you know and actually this time when
when we got back she was complaining how
hard it was to get back into that we
didn't how demanding it was demanding it
is yeah it was difficult to stay away
because yes that he was leaving camp so
if you wanted to stay in touch with her
friends right yeah how do you do that
now yeah so I want to I want to play on
this point when we talk about the the
new world this next world that we're
going to and what are some of the
existing technologies we've listed some
of them we have the psychedelics then
Thea Jen's the meditation we have other
experiences of non-separation
of interconnectedness that are starting
to also be administered through other
biotech and neuro tech virtual reality
augmented reality experiences that help
awaken people to that deep
interconnectedness we have
decentralization technologies and
cryptocurrencies that are literally that
have in the actual protocol themselves
of how it actually functions is an
interconnected system and not a
centralized system the cannabis and hemp
market there's all these different new
up-and-coming ways for us to be able to
bring forth technologies that help us
build the new world and democratize the
fruits that come from the prosperities
across the plane to people and not
concentrate it in just the 1% right and
I think that's you know possibly those
are all opportunities I want to say two
things about that
that came to mind as you were talking
one is the the Hopi and other Pueblo
people they have what's called emergence
stories so they merge into one world and
then they live there and then they fall
out of balance you know things don't
work out because they don't follow what
usually is called the original
instructions you know how to be in
balance basically so those who were
still in balance they escaped to the
next world right and on and on so the
question is will we be able to do this
with balance right and I think if we are
not self-actualization self actualizing
in an interconnected manner way where
our self doesn't have these thick
boundaries but is really sort of more
osmotic as model where you know the
sources that can feed us can actually
reach us you know whether it's the
clouds or whether it's other people what
what whatever it is so that's one thing
I want to say then the other thing is
which is you know I love that vision the
osmotic vision is yeah yeah yeah yes
though the other thing the other part is
I think we are in the process and I
don't know where this process will go I
don't know if there will be a new world
maybe there won't be a new home we're
building it we got this we got this
right but we are you know in what you
described is basically we are
externalizing
were interconnections right so rather
than using our psyches to interconnect
we're using the technology to inter
connect right so and and is that going
to work out or not or is that another
stage in dissociation or are we gonna be
able to utilize these tremendous
technological powers really for our
benefit as a tool right yeah and you
know my basic contention would be if we
find ways to ground ourselves and then
do this I think there's a possibility
that we're going to be fine but if we
because this is so and meshed with you
know profit and all of that then we
dissociate more and separate ourselves
more yeah um yes source and you know
it's it's so embedded right I mean like
Facebook right I feel totally embedded
in about Facebook because on the one
hand it allows for interconnection or
connection and then there's which is
their main pitch which is their main
pitch the neck the world it's it's the
right wrench Ryan the Google's was do no
evil right these main pitches and the
way that some house there's also
something deeper that is also a little
bit darker that emerges that needs to be
addressed well and a lot of that has to
do with quantification data and profit
right and if you and that's you know I'm
sure you've heard or read gerald linear
you know he says we're in the wrong
model here yeah you know I'm clearly
it's not that the technology or the
ideas are wrong but the way it is
financed the way it works yes that is
what's creating the pathologies and we
need to find a way to overcome
and right now with all the big companies
I don't see any intention to overcome it
right no least we have full people like
Marc Benioff we're doing is seems like
they're pushing for like when you're
calling Facebook like cigarettes right
you're at least starting to draw
attention a little bit more yes yeah so
that's that's interesting stuff yeah
yeah and I think that that's helpful
because we need to have powerful
metaphors that actually show what's
going on here
yeah you know um these two that you
bring up they have this central essence
to them which you've been again coming
at over and over again I really like it
this if we're gonna move into the
interconnected age that in order for us
which we did we're talking about with
indigenous these immediate return
hunter-gatherer style living so we meet
is so interconnected that if we're gonna
take our modern modernity into that
interconnected age there's a there's a
way to do it that that makes it so that
people can feel like they have love that
they have a deep feelings of non
separation and there's other ways to do
it that are like you were just listing
with these issues with that we're having
right now with big tech so what are the
ways that we're moving into the
interconnected era are we moving into
them with this double-edged ness with a
technology like we were just describing
with multiple ones or are we moving in
with what we make ask complete love and
ask complete interconnection and
feelings of belonging feelings of coming
alive us having a stake in you bringing
your gifts to the world well right now
as I'm sitting here and as I'm inter
connecting with you I don't need any
technology right I mean even though
we're surrounded by technology and you
know this is going to be broadcast by a
technology etc etc but we can have a
connect
we enter connections in our
conversations before and all of that
yeah and if that's what's being
facilitated I think we can be alright
even the addiction of technology so
often separates us from that level of
conversation and interconnection yeah
whether it's the reduction of vocabulary
that happens with social media use
Twitter etc etc where introspection
becomes you know difficult yes you know
or you know we can think of other things
that where as we grow up I mean I have
students who they can't be without their
phone in the classroom and I say yeah
put your phone in a place where you
can't easily get to it you know don't
just turn it around you know put it like
somewhere where use if it into your
backpack or or whatever right because
there is that addiction you know which
elastic talks about and others talk
about yeah and I think that really
distracts us from the love that you were
talking about you know the connection
with erotic life forests with you know
being alive and experiencing that and I
think you know if we can see these
things as tools but also if we can see
them as having a spirit of some form
yeah then we relate differently yeah but
you know spirit and profit don't go very
well together except maybe in the new
age
mmm there's that right that's such a
crazy question right there what would be
a future where those could somehow arm
in some ways it feels like even now
people that have made profit in some
cases are able to help increase the
amount of spirit and unconscious
evolution that occurs through what
they've been able to do yeah this takes
you know a profound ethic and you know
this is what you know in the Buddhist
precepts you find you know their ethical
assumptions and their of how you live
your life yeah and actually at one point
I rewrote the Buddhist you know the
basic precepts sort of as a way to be
more inclusive of indigenous and in some
ways a little bit more contemporary you
know and so that you know that practice
is really really important there so I
don't we knew we have a couple other
areas that we need to go to I wanna you
know we talked about this as well this
optical delusion of separate separation
how it's basically this persistent
phenomenon of the feeling of separation
but it's a complete illusion it's a
complete delusion but it's also
conscious the separation is unconscious
you see which means there's you know
there there's unconscious suffering but
the suffering is not in your face
because you take the drug again right
mm-hmm because so you stay unconscious
and how to hack into that by analyzing
are why we do what we do analyzing our
behaviors and our patterns and then
being able to intervene strategically to
make ourselves more conscious very
important we um you wrote an entire book
ethnography and you guys can find that
book as well on your against page ethno
autobiography really resonates deeply
with me because there's some sort of a I
just like seven years ago I just
couldn't stop wanting to write
everything that I was learning down into
my notes and I wanted to continuously
reflect on what I was learning in the
world and why I was parsing for these
profound things that were happening and
then writing them in the notes and now
we're over 3,000 note files that we have
in Evernote and there's one for you and
there's a bunch for Horry and there's a
one for every single guest and there's
one for all these different types of
topics and all the different projects
we're working on so it's just so
interesting that that process hasn't
made me understand who I am better I
want you to speak about that because if
we don't have some sort of reflective
process that helps us understand who we
are better how else can we do that we
need to have some sort of a goal that we
go for that we know is our essence our
spirit our gift and that we want to go
for that and we know these little steps
to take along the way to bring that
forth into the world to manifest it so
one of the things I'm very careful with
is using terms like essence because I
believe we are very much in process hmm
so what may appear is your essence today
if I ask you jokes
what is Alan's essence you would give me
a sensible answer in just a remove it
can shake sure right yeah and in a month
you know maybe it doesn't change
dramatically but it will be somewhat
different fair right yeah so really
whatever the truth self the essence of
who we are is really a moving target
essence is evolutionary right right and
again I rather use process rather than
evolutionary process you know and it's
part of this
Singh process I'm trying to get away
from the progress model which i think is
part of our pathology yeah right yeah
because when you see somebody when you
see a tightrope walker balancing herself
that's very beautiful when you see that
and it's very extraordinary right so we
don't need progress right when the Hopi
balanced themselves in a Kachina dance
they don't need progress now I don't
mean to say that everything that we've
done should be just thrown out but we
need to develop a different relationship
to it progress and balance well um
that's closer that's closer and I would
just stick with balance sorry um yeah
sound almost fundamentalist I don't mean
to do that but also their salads
we have sink we also have the this
system that we have right in front of us
that's enabling us to broadcast these
messages because of progress at the same
time but girl but conscious progress
though of where did we source these
materials how did we respect the process
of our interconnectedness as we made
this these are very important principles
but why do we need process progress
because we lost our way yeah so let me
talk for a minute about the discipline
of ethanol autobiography yes okay
because you know I think for anybody to
keep a diary to do that kind of self
inquiring to write down our insights on
all of that is terribly important and
useful because there's something that
when we you know work with our writing
whether it's with a computer or with by
hand
you know that's helpful you know it's a
form of inquiry it's a form of learning
it's a form of
that facilitates transformation yes but
then there are these different aspects
of who we are right because we live in a
biosphere II we live in a world that you
know may be more natural if we live out
somewhere outside of town or we may be
whatever in downtown San Francisco in
Manhattan or wherever we are well that's
an ecology - that's a that's a biosphere
- that has an impact when we have our
ethnosphere our culture that our culture
has you know numerous subcultures right
and we identify with different
subcultures you know whatever you are
touching into the Silicon Valley
subculture and whoever comes through
here and that's a part of your culture
and but that's not all of you right you
as a part of some meditative spiritual
questing culture right so all these so
we're complex so there's that part but
then the other aspect is our
spirituality or religion right and or
our atheism or agnosticism you know but
we need to find those answers - where
are we from why we're here and where
we're going these you know very
fundamental questions there's no way
around it yeah you know then who's our
community you know in community again
can mean human community but it can also
mean our our animals our plants they're
also part of our community in the Andes
it's so beautiful when the natives there
talk about community that includes the
mountains and the llamas and
you know everything that girl was there
in the quinoa what have you so that's
all community yes I had a relationship
right and you know those are
environments if you're not intimate with
them you you'll perish right yeah you
and I would perish if we have to live in
these hills for two weeks yeah right
because we don't know where to find the
food or how to catch the rabbits or
whatever it is yes yes so then there is
you know the dealing with a shadow of
them that I mentioned earlier so so
there there is a discipline in trying to
reconstitute an indigenous process it's
you know one of the things that's really
hard for people of modernity is we like
to fantasize about the Plains Indian you
know and say oh these beautiful Warriors
etc etc right and we have these
fantasies which have nothing to do with
anybody native as we have a lot of
fantasies about black people right they
have nothing to do with who black people
actually really are we we can't even see
them right and so part of the work is to
to cleanse our our lenses in that way
and to rip the veil so that we can
actually see that we can see our history
yes and that we all have stories right
now you know one of the things when we
talk about indigenous recovery of
indigenous minds is it's not about going
back because we can't go back we can't
go back in history right we have to go
forward but we have to go forward with
the awareness of where we're coming from
in my ancestral culture you know there's
there's a well of memories one of the
central images and but in order to take
a step forward you first have to take a
step
back and that enables you then to take
the step forward and for me this is a
tremendously powerful image yeah because
I need to bring the past with me and as
soon as I go into the denial about the
past all of it I'm in trouble because
I'm not fully present and you know
whether you go to the Buddhist teachings
about presence or indigenous teachings
about presence you know when I don't do
that I'm not I'm not fully present and
that's the the discipline you know so
ethno autobiography means that I look at
all these differences you know gender
you know all these different aspects of
myself yeah and do kind of a self
inquiry self-examination yes so yeah
then I can start to be again in this
osmotic relationship with the world yes
around me and we always you know we are
so categorical and abstract right and we
kind of hate a certain level of fluidity
because it's much harder to handle
right I mean male and female that's easy
right but if there's more than male and
female you know people can't very often
can't handle it and we're not educated
to handle it and our society doesn't
know how to handle intersex intersex you
know that which are actually real
biological things yeah yeah yeah real
and I really I'm just so appreciative of
your depth with ethno autobiography
because you use you listed for several
minutes all of these key influences that
we have on who we are but when we don't
do that deep amount of self inquiry that
dive that gives us a more well-rounded
interconnected picture of who we are and
our lineages and all these other
variables that impact
who we are then it makes it so that we
are not as aware as we move forward in
the world and so it's it's a big
challenge to our awareness is to do
these exercises these ethno
autobiographical exercises and one thing
I have mentioned as dreams you know we
talked earlier I love my dream note I
just wake up and I have to write it down
before going right to bed yeah yeah yeah
so you know because that's a natural
integrative states of consciousness that
we go through everybody goes through
whether we remember our dreams or not
right and so much of the hunger for
altered states and entheogens and all
that desire is really you know because
in those states what happens you know
when we go into a trance or when
somebody takes asset or whatever it is
right there is a synchronization that
happens between the hemispheres but also
a synchronization with the older parts
of our brain and part of you know the
left brain dominance is a disconnection
from imagery which is why movies are so
powerful right because they speak to the
other parts of ourselves right because
the verbage and movies is certainly
important but it's really the imagery
yes you know that dream you know
Hollywood has the Dream Factory you know
that that really entices us I had this
funny image yesterday or the day before
I don't know did you which one was it
did you see the movie Joe Joe Rabbit I
don't think so well you should watch it
sure Joe rabbit okay yes and it's about
category it's about this kid
in Germany who has an imaginary playmate
the imaginary playmate is Hitler
so all so that easily could go down the
drain right but it's done right now I
was a matter and part of what happens is
because Hitler is so over the top right
because it's also comedy right it
becomes so apparent how insane Hitler is
and how insane the whole system was now
I imagine somebody with modernity has an
imaginary playmate and what is the actor
director and actor white titi Waikiki
ytt I think from Maury that playing
modernity over-the-top mmm yes yes yes
that's getting it so loud be a comedy
yeah that's how making it so obvious in
this character yes yes what is wrong
with it yes I I also deeply was started
creating artistic expressions of this in
image and video where it's things like
the these indigenous dances like you
were describing earlier and right next
to them are like a like a US and a
Chinese programmer on their laptops and
they're both coding super intelligence
for artificial intelligence general
intelligence and they're telling the
indigenous people you will quiet down so
we can focus you know and so just like
these types of means and and real and
just ways for people to kind of like
juxtapose
such profoundly different roots and
modernity
yeah and that's so awakening I really
think you can make it comedic in
Awakening I like that a lot I'm really
I'm a huge advocate of creating
multimedia content that has around these
styles of awakening yeah that's part of
what I've done this as artists because
there's the whole other side of me
where I know then have time to paint but
I love creating multimedia shows yeah
where you know the imagery and the sound
you know to really shift people and
shift people's awareness yes and allow
for for insight yes we have we have we
have so much more to still talk about
let's begin uh abnormal psychology okay
I section this uh I want you to take it
off but I'm just ridiculously I want to
I want to approach it from this
perspective we're we're we're giving
this example that we were just in with
these roots and modernity and modernity
has in many ways created some of the
main issues that we have with our
psychology and our mental health and
wellness right and then furthermore is
that there are these these collective
hallucinations that we have we've
created hyper realities where we say
that this money has a certain amount of
value and that's something that we all
agree on and that Santa Claus comes down
your chimney and eats the cookies and
gives you presents it's a complete hyper
reality that is embedded now in people's
lives from childhood and so when we talk
about things like abnormal psychology or
schizophrenia being able to see maybe
different reality simultaneously and
question what is actually real when I
see money I see a hallucinate 'add money
but I also see the way that money is a
real thing in the world and so what how
do you feel about abnormal psychology
it's a Freni aware do you take things
off well I'm tempted to start out with a
story about Santa Claus and okay greatly
daring enough to mention Santa Claus
do you want to hear this truth about
Santa Claus yes yes so and when I was
growing up on our Christmas tree
they were always fly agaric what's that
it's a hell of sin of genic mushroom oh
and then I went and spent time with the
sami people up in the Arctic which is
where Santa Claus or one of so they're
Santa Claus in this land there are
reindeer and right in front of the
reindeer are the fly agaric though a
part of it is if you don't treat fly
agaric right you die hey hey
yes okay but reindeer don't
these are reindeer you get high without
dying right so the way to do it I should
get a reindeer to eat the fly agaric and
then you eat the reindeer urine but
anyway Wow Santa Claus was flying yeah
yeah he was flying on a hell of cinnamon
oh my gosh so what so there's this story
so ok ok but you wanted to know about
abnormal psychology so the first thing I
want to say I don't like the term
abnormal psychology or mental illness
any of these terms because what we are
really talking about is that individuals
are severely suffering so I call it
severe psychological suffering which is
very awkward and I wish I had a shorter
way of saying it yeah but through
technology or cycle they're true it's
such as P oops SPS since they're
psychologically I mean so to acknowledge
to really terms are really important
humanity in it because so much of
diagnosing is stigmatizing now the first
profound issue that you raised was
really kind of where we started which is
our social or cultural path all
Yeah right yeah now Eric from famous
psychoanalyst who was involved with
critical theory he had this measure that
really the question is not can the crazy
person adjust to society but yes to what
extent does society actually serve us
prevent craziness yeah to what extent a
society they actually built for humans
right yeah and a lot of what we've
talked about was really about well at
this moment society is not really built
for that and we need to change it and
yeah you know you keep talking about
awakening and evolution right the hope
that that shifts yeah right so so part
of that is you know and when Einstein
talked about delusion right well that's
a cultural pathology and delusion well
if you're schizophrenic then you have
delusions or you know that's one of the
things one of the symptoms right and so
we are living in a delusional universe
according to Albert Einstein's diagnosis
so there are these social pathologies
now I think part of what we're
struggling with and I think way the way
there is this pressure for change is
that we are now seeing an increasing
number of symptoms that indicate this
normative dissociation yeah you and hari
talks for example about depression well
you know if I put you into a little
cubicle yes and it's between you and the
computer and you do that for eight hours
a day yeah and you have very little
control over what you're doing it is not
surprising that you would get depressed
yeah right so when I talked earlier
about ethanol autobiography and our
osmotic self and finding or recovering
these interconnections
that's also a remedy for depression
right yes we enter into a nurturing
conversation with all the things around
us so severe psychological suffering can
actually be remedied by deep feelings of
non-separation and interconnectedness
and belonging in bringing your gifts
into the world yes
and I'm not you know I'm not saying
they're also biochemical equivalents etc
etc yes right yes yes um so and I think
we haven't talked about this but you
know my model is non reductionistic so I
I see you know when when you eat it
impacts your your chemistry
when you have thought it impacts your
neural chemistry so if you continue
giving yourself negative thoughts it
also impacts your brain patterns and
your feelings etc etc yeah on the
reverse if you take a certain drug then
it also impacts your thought patterns
right and they mirror each other they
interact and they're in these complex
feedback loops which are really these in
my imagination these complex quantum
equations of probabilities and these
equations are very long and they can be
impacted at various points right so when
a depressed person actually gets
reconnected with what feeds us oh then
you know the person will in all
probability feel better yeah right so
when we go alive feel alive
right so the biomedical model has only
one answer you're depressed you have
severe depression here's a genocidal
goal you take a pharmaceutical and
that's the only way to deal with it
right now there are many people who've
done otherwise that successfully dealt
with and so what that kind of analysis
cuts out is
that actually depression is not just an
individual problem it's certainly
individual suffering but it's a social
issue as is much of when we talk about
whatever PTSD etc are the many issues
that we can talk about that have a very
strong social component
I like Phil borgeous was on our show too
and he went so deep into understanding
how indigenous we're talking about this
over and over again how this deep
interconnected wisdom people had seance
people had deep mystical experiences
above and that there's ways to actually
be able to see that today as profoundly
fascinating and needing to be studied
more rather than just saying that this
is some craziness and that let's brush
it off and get past it these are
profound experiences that need to be
studied more and understood more what is
going on with the person when they're
feeling something experiencing something
channeling something that is not
necessarily of this physical world
that's beautiful right and in our
society for many people there's no place
to go and they start feeling crazy yes
Jerome Bernstein who was a Jungian
analyst in Santa Fe he has this
beautiful term border Landers and those
are people who are particularly
sensitive to what for example what goes
on in the environment and they feel they
don't just recognize that I understand
they feel the pain of the environment he
feels they'll actually feel the trees
being divorced in the oceans being
acidified this is very interesting
borderland or sporter land as the term
and so they are you know most diagnostic
categories are totally individual
stick just focused on the on the
individual there are very few when we
talk about cultural stress and a few
other things that sort of reach out into
what is around the individuals and you
know border lenders the way he talks
about it is is one of the ways yes yet I
think it's very important to understand
em severe psychological suffering you
know also in the social Oh
interesting here's and it may be an
interesting point of clarification that
severe psychological suffering and let's
say SPS a were would work with something
like a depression like we were listening
earlier but it actually doesn't work
with what we were just talking about
which is a border Landers a border lamb
bruises maybe more of like an abnormal
so a border lander needs the support of
a person of a competitor yet or a friend
or a medicine person or a shaman or a
spiritual person healer of some fourth
who can understand what they're feeling
yes and help them yet to express what
they're seeing exactly takes into action
and we need this we assure them that how
this is not crazy actually what you're
yes yes is something that is happening
for real so okay so then actually rather
than saying that that is abnormal so
that is actually normal that is actually
deep interconnected feelings and we are
abnormal when we don't feel that right
okay so this is the better way to
clarify it's and severe psychological
suffering is getting like a depression
so normal a biospheric psychology when
you're actually deeply immersed in non
separation is when you can feel stuff
like that and you we need better support
networks right for border Landers and
stuff like this and we need more people
to move from the abnormal in the
modernity in the metropolis into states
of interconnectedness right yeah right
yeah
yeah yeah into normal psyche
interconnected psychology yeah and you
know and the addiction to whatever
consumerism etc you know sort of creates
a buffer where we don't experience the
loss right where we can just sort of
continue on doing what we always have
done you know and our educational system
doesn't do anything to prevent that
right to give students the capacity to
go inside and to go into the
interconnection and nurture themselves
which is one of the great failures of
our educational system agreed yes yeah
so you know and and there are many
things that are going well but we need
to complement it you know that that's
really the major point there yeah what
do you think is the future of mythology
mythology the way I understand it our
stories that come out of integrative
states of consciousness of profound
experiences profound encounters with
spiritual realities altered states etc
etc there are being brought back by the
people who experienced that and for some
reason there's something in these
stories that are of collective value so
there is an insight in there where other
people say that makes sense to me so
they keep telling the stories again and
again so it's not just a personal
mythology standing Kurt no talks about
personal mythology but a mythology that
has meaning beyond the personal and
speaks to a group or parts of a group
yes so now where do these stories come
from they are not fantasized I make a
distinction between fantasy and
imagination
so fantasy is
when we're not connected fantasy are
when we're in a dissociative State
imagination is when our thinking and
imagery is connected with our emotional
brain and with our body our embodiment
and that's you know where that's
mythology so when we want to renew
mythology or think about the future of
mythology the only way to renew it is
through our dreams and through going to
these edges of ourselves and coming back
with stories that are are meaningful and
inspiring and that explain something
right a story that had explained well
are we in a simulation borrowing up in a
simulation is this are we in a progress
model are we not you know what what so
that deals with that yeah and that
profound encounter with the unconscious
with the deepest level of the
unconscious that's where the future
mythology can emerge but part of that is
also the work with the old mythology and
see you know how can we carry that
forward would come what comes up for
that and we need mythologies to we need
stories we're storytellers we need that
but we can't just make them up you know
and it's nothing against fiction fiction
is fantastic fiction is really important
right but mythologies carry beyond that
because they are so deeply connected and
very often mythologies and traditional
societies and indigenous societies are
enacted they're ritually enacted they're
performed their embodied rather because
it's about the the embodiment and so the
imagination the mythic imagination
of the Hopi look a little bit different
from the mythic imagination to their
neighboring Cochiti right related yes
yes similar environment but different
imagination different performance
different practice so it could be fair
to say that the future of Mythology is
something along the lines of creating
stories that can inspire further
awakening and can us it can show us in a
very potentially succinct and beautiful
and way that stays with us over
generations that is fun to teach a way
that gets people to kind of realize I
was kind of envisioning this as we were
talking just this idea that as you move
from maybe more rural tribal areas into
more metropolis as concrete jungles you
don't get to look at the stars you have
there's light pollution so if you know
you don't get to when you look at a tree
you don't necessarily get to see the
fruits of the tree and the roots of the
tree and the way that the tree houses
other insects and birds and it does
photosynthesis you don't get to see that
but if you have the right glasses right
if you have the right if you have the
right vision you can actually see that
if you're a wise person you can see that
compared to when you're you know buying
food at a grocery store you don't
actually see the farm and how it
happened so these are may be the ways to
communicate stories in myth that help us
awaken more yes and there is also a
necessity clearly and I don't know how
they're gonna come about for stories
that facilitate change because yeah
there there is seeing and understanding
and then there is changing our practices
you know whether it's how we treat
animals that end up with the butcher's
or whatever it is or industrial
agriculture you know you're gonna feel
like they're so important by play a
massive
role in the future of telling stories
that facilitate change mm-hmm that's one
of my biggest feelings about my gifts
and yeah I'm I'm very excited I think
you know these conversations are you
know working on that story what is that
story and part of that is how do we get
the story right you know how and then
that's why it's so good you know when we
come at it from different angle we
angles we emphasize different things but
it's this search you know not just for
words but also for words that connect us
in a deeper way yes our being in visuals
visual videos that connect us deeper to
our being into each other and so you you
nailed it there that all of these
conversations are exactly what's going
into the stories that are being
synthesized and disseminated I want to
ask you about your your focus on healing
as well because we were listing the kind
of some of these possible ways of
feelings of non-separation helps us a
lot other meditations or psychedelics
Anthea jhin's or other feelings of
belonging or aliveness other modalities
to solve some of the most complex
psychological sufferings yeah so what
are your thoughts on like on you know
there's all these different types of
neuro technological solutions around
about with with brain stimulation
there's there's lots of interesting
biofeedback mechanisms that can occur
that can help people get away from
suffering how do you feel about the
future of that for you well my first
answer is whatever works yeah yeah
whatever works you know shamans are very
pragmatic and hopefully what our
medicine is also mostly pragmatic and of
just ideological and dogmatic right
because a times Western medicine works
and at times that doesn't work
at times a shamanic intervention works
and at times it doesn't
yes so part of that is actually getting
good differential diagnosis that's it as
it were right so healing can happen in
all kinds of ways the the way I look at
healing is you know most healers when
you ask them well or did you do the
healing a lot of them will say I didn't
do it I was just the Condors I was the
conduit I was that a channel right yeah
so part of you know the way I understand
that is that they offer their energies
so that the person who wants the healing
can trigger their self healer and that
you know the religious term for this is
grace that grace can come in mm-hmm so a
healer opens the door and then something
there's an opportunity for something to
happen yeah and you know some seen a
healer say well you know I mean
Rolling Thunder is one of the healers I
knew and you know at times it wasn't
right to do the healing right he
couldn't see it right by the times also
you know you have healers well where is
the intention of the person is the
person going there has that will
intention determination you know yes any
times the person has the determination
but it stills not happened grace is not
there the the door is there but
something is not right about it so you
know I think as a healer one has the
obligation to to create and make
available whatever gifts the healer has
make that energy available so that the
person can we constantly him or herself
so you know you know
about the strange attractor and mmm and
that pattern right so it's like our
habitual way of constructing ourselves
as a particular pattern into strange
attractors in a particular place so part
of the work of the healer is to shift
the strange attractor so that a
different pattern can emerge or to
create that opportunity for that to
happen yeah yeah I love that I love that
so so then it's up to our social fabric
to design new ways to make it so that
healing can more effectively occur
growth conscious evolution can occur
yeah I mean I merely Ixchel you know if
anybody you know has a serious illness
serious suffering whether psychological
or medical there is a team of people who
works holistically with everything from
whatever the biochemical analysis to the
psychological analysis you know and and
uses different approaches and different
ways of analyzing the situation we're so
far away from it because we have this
biomedical model that is so
reductionistic that all we're doing is
well let's analyze this and see what is
the right drug well the drug may be
absolutely the right thing to do but
maybe not or it may be insufficient yeah
and you know the the distinction between
the symptom and the cause of the
illnesses are also just really important
yes and a future that I love to think
about is we're just as frequently as you
see the food in a metropolis where you
see food everywhere there's food options
on every corner why is there not growth
and healing and conscious evolution
options on every corner right that's a
future that I love I love thinking about
people like Ori and other spiritual
sages that can come and bring their
gifts forth on the different corners of
these areas and have students
come and learn and grow and evolve in
that sort of feedback loop with with the
teacher of one on one and that in that
style actually doesn't even require
sometimes oh we need to take a complete
biometric readout of this person and you
know it actually is just I - I face like
we were been doing for the longest time
although you can get gain great insights
from biometrics you could potentially
complement them together yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah
you see I think good education is
healing yeah you know that's what
education you know obviously we need to
get information we need to learn things
that are cognitive etc etc but there's a
part where it should further the
balancing and the integration of the
person that should be healing and
education is so far yes for the most
part there are exceptions as always you
know we're talking a broad generalities
here there are always exceptions but you
know so far away from that
why aren't schools using the integrative
states of consciousness yes race yes a
trance you don't even need to talk about
psychedelics or anything like that no I
mean there are very simple ways through
art movement drumming chanting yes
cetera of deep immersion in nature in
each other's a house also with the
integration and that are not utilized
you see from the youngest ages you need
to be so one of the ways why I realized
why I'm always hesitant to say oh yeah
whatever
a I or a technology or will will will do
this for us right is that I think we
actually know everything we need to know
except we haven't figured out how to
actually put it to use how to implement
it how to implement it there is so much
yeah that we actually already know
yeah but we don't know how to use it for
our balancing ma social level on a
cultural level you know we're and
there's old codes and incumbents that
want to propagate the old archaic
infrastructure yeah propagate them with
read in an hour
yeah those into profits sure I like that
perspective though that we already know
a lot of so much yeah yeah you know
which isn't to say that it's easy to
implement yeah it obviously isn't yeah
correct it's hard heavy how do you take
what is happening in indigenous cultures
and bring that into metropolis yeah yeah
good luck yeah and we also know like
self love and self compassion is
critical for happiness right it's not an
easy yeah just right it's critic do we
forgive ourselves for our mistakes when
we lose it when we're writing apologize
and and not an easy practice yeah right
and say that I want to grow and become
better yeah that's so important yeah um
you teach in a in a way that I think is
really interesting on some of the final
points here you teach in a way that
incorporates modern-day like movies into
your teaching like you like this right
you'll show like a scene in a modern-day
movie like a Harry Potter and then
you'll work with your class on
indicating the the dynamics of
interconnectedness with even with other
people in the environment and yeah yeah
I think you see information is is really
easy it's the integration of the
information that's difficult yes right
so in my teaching what I'm trying to do
is have the information easily
accessible right but really like in the
class work on the integration and movies
are one
of the powerful ways of doing it like
right now I'm using a movie which is
initially students really kind of
freaked out because it's an Ingmar
Bergman movie and it's subtitled and
it's in black and white
alright so three strikes against it
right and it's the movie wild
strawberries which can be used to
illustrate developmental phases and
human development right and it's a
beautifully done movie and students
always get into it
they always say oh I would have never
watched this movie on my own and I'm
glad that you actually made us watch it
right because the power of the story the
power of the visuals you know and
Bergman has such deep psychological
insights you know it works and it works
in a kind of holistic way that you know
just talking about the developmental
phases just doesn't do it quite in the
same way so that that's an example I
show another movie that's actually it's
a documentary
it's called hey Doc well sorry you know
that's the horse boy I also show ha doc
which is a very interesting movie it's a
mongolian movie about a child who has
unusual experiences he goes into what
looks like epileptic seizures but he's
really called to be a shaman a healer
and he refuses a gift because of the
Soviet rule you know shamanism was
really repressed and person shamans were
persecuted so there was nobody to guide
him right
so but it gives a visual experience of
the challenges and the opportunities and
in a horse boy that's actually a movie
was showing how an autistic child gets
better
and functions better because of shamanic
experiences yeah Mongolia yes so I love
this style of teaching and for students
learning where it helps them with the
efficacy of landing the teachings and
integrating it for that right what's the
greatest level of efficacy that a
teacher can have with their students
that's a big question or in the content
on the memes that are delivered on the
visuals and videos to make the most
efficient well the most important part
is to be for the teacher I think to be
present to the students make yourself
present to the students like we were out
of school for a week because of the
fires in Santa Rosa well on Tuesday I'm
not just gonna start class like normal
like normal right r-huh
what's what's going on so I allow them
to check in yes and address whatever the
issues they're all have different
experiment home with their families Yeah
right yeah some air qualities all the
stuff yeah and because we had a fire
major fire two years ago this also has
been triggering for students because you
know that was a major yeah
disaster yeah you know so when you start
there and see where your students are
and that then you help the integration
yeah yeah yeah agree it's really
important yeah you know where they're at
in their process ok the couple quick
questions that we like asking on the way
out the first question is do you what do
you think of this statement okay
Humanity is a biological
bootloader for digital super
intelligence III think you know again we
talked about it earlier you know is this
just a way of rationalizing our
dissociation or is there actually
something in there or what are we
actually learning from it right now I am
on the on the negative side of the
equation so to speak because I don't see
us as having the capacity yet to see
these things as tools and not as
all-consuming and addictive and all of
that you know so it's almost like I'm
not ready to talk about it because
people should know how they survive out
there in those hills for two weeks and
then we can talk about it because then
we're more ethically and philosophically
morally spiritually present to what
we're building yeah yeah okay then nice
talk and then let's talk about it yeah
like I like this yeah so that's okay
yeah okay how about what has been one of
your if not the deepest feeling that
you've had while being immersed in
creation here the deepest feeling yeah
well I think the deepest feeling
probably for me was being able to go to
the source of creation and messing with
my DNA code how's that mm and how how
how I turned into a lizard and started
to go there what does that mean so there
was an integrative state of
consciousness where we
profoundly in to my own programming and
[Music]
looked at it and was able to be aware of
it and had the experience of being able
to do something about it which by the
way biological research now shows that
octopuses which are amazing yes they can
change the RNA yeah which is
extraordinary
right yeah so but I think for me that
was a profound experience because it
showed me how deep we could go inside of
ourselves and it was really you know
when you go really deep inside you
really go deep outside I mean it's like
inside outside you know become very
different in relation you know you go to
some in this case basic structures I'm
just imagining you going deep into that
uh and just reading the code and then
just like you know reprogramming what
yeah yeah that's such an important deep
surgical process into one psyche to be
more aligned with the interconnectedness
and their divine purpose yeah yeah how
about do you think we're in a simulation
if I were wanted to be flippant I would
say who cares why do you care so but
more serious answer is it makes no
difference right I still need to balance
myself I still need to be ethical I
still need to you know lead my life in
them a balanced creative way that I'm
looking for it makes no difference for
that so it doesn't change anything that
I'm doing and again it's a point where I
can go and lose myself in these
deliberations while in fact it would be
much better to smell a flower
mmm interesting so focusing on the inner
engineering and going through that
process and the the interconnected
engineering and experience is really
profoundly important and then also while
doing that I found the thought
experiments of simulation to be
extremely important for my understanding
of all of the potentials that may be and
that us as also potential creators of in
the future quadrillions of these
simulations and watching them grow us
either petri dishes or making
interventions along the way and seeing
what flourishes from that I think will
give us deeper insight about who we are
where we came from that type of stuff
so I don't know if this is how you
understand simulation but if you
understand simulation is imagination mmm
mm-hmm then I can relate to it because
for me imagination is a process that is
profoundly connected within myself and
if that's what we're talking about then
I could say well the Hopi are a
particular cultural simulation the Old
Norse were a particular cultural
simulation the whatever right and our
modern society is a particular cultural
even simulation but the subculture is
there such these realities yeah yeah but
for me you see what Einstein talks about
the delusion of disconnection that for
me is always the curse sort of the
testing point and if my simulation
emerges from an interconnectedness then
it has a different quality
and just a mind game there's nothing
wrong with mind games there can be
entertaining at all of that fair yeah
but really if it's sort of without a
body so to speak yeah yeah there's
something missing so yeah for me when
you go into that place that gets
interesting yeah feel the
interconnectedness and now get to your
yah yah yah yah next step last question
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in creation well I just listened
to Charles Eisenstein before and he said
you know the birth of his daughters I
think the birth of my daughter was
definitely you know extraordinary but
for me just like watching a plant sprout
is just magical that's just like your
daughter in a census your plants
sprouting as well oh yeah this is
extraordinary
right yeah or you have a seed right and
you put that seed into the dirt yes and
then something happens right and you go
how or you know the butterfly or
whatever you know these these
transformations that are you know we can
explain a lot of it but we don't
understand a lot of it a flowering of
conscious yes you know so yeah or he had
that yesterday too the flowering of
consciousness I love it so beautiful
yeah yeah and collectively as well the
collective flowering - you know I love
that as beauty as Beauty is the most
beautiful thing yeah
the plant of the saffron crocus us to
grow saffron yeah just coming up oh just
you know yeah out of this world yes yes
to have that amount of devotion to some
of the most simple things is crucial
yeah and yet most complex things as well
yeah but that's a presence and
interconnection right yes connect itself
that is you know yes that's a non
dissociated self when we go there and I
don't blame not to be normatively
dissociated yeah yeah yeah I'm part of
our pathology you know but you know
likewise in many ways and also try to
heal us and move us in the yeah yeah
you're again I must say that this has
been one of my favorite conversations
and I look forward to rewatching this
episode and taking notes because there
have been a lot of profound realizations
for me and that I now need to go and and
relist into and write down this has been
so enlightening thank you for coming on
the show very welcome thank you for
having me and I really enjoyed our
conversation thanks thanks for all your
great work thank you thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciated we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations with your
friends families co-workers people
online about the topics that we talked
about on the show about the fallacious
self about ethno autobiography about the
optical delusion of separateness about
the recovery of the indigenous mind
about abnormal psychology the future of
mythology all of these topics and let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
on them check out the link in the bio
below to uragan and his work check those
out check out his books check out those
links everyone thank you to Ori Shapira
for co-producing thank you very much Ori
and also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders spiritual
sages in your communities that you
believe in support them support the ones
around the world also help them grow you
can find our links below to our show and
you can support us your donations to
simulation mean the world to helping us
flower thank you thank you and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world we love very much
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you soon peace